well let's get the latest take now we're
joined by the shadow secretary of state
for digital cultural media and sport
lucy powell who joins us now and thanks
for being with us um what is your
reaction to see grey's report
well i mean it's it's very revealing
isn't it the industrial scale
partying that was happening at downing
street the lack of judgment the poor
leadership the fact that these things
were allowed to go ahead with great
frequency and that they were sanctioned
uh in in effect and the sue grey report
makes clear that that book really should
stop with the prime minister and the
political leadership of downing street
but we heard from the prime minister
today that while he says he takes
responsibility he's not owning any
responsibility at all because he's not
taking any action himself or recognizing
that he himself is at fault it seemed to
be
everybody else's fault but his own the
secret report it obviously does
it obviously you know really condemn a
lot of what went on in number 10 but at
the same time it does feel like it stops
short of calling for boris johnson to
resign if you like and she also says in
her report in her conclusions that she's
pleased that progress is being made in
addressing the issues i raised we heard
brother lewis saying that there have
been changes of personnel in downing
streets so
do you accept that sue gray appears to
be at least partially satisfied that the
government's listening well look at the
end of the day sue gray although she's a
woman of great integrity i know sue and
of course she is and she did an
independent inquiry she is nonetheless a
civil servant and she makes that clear
in her report as well that it's not for
her
to issue disciplinary action or
sanctions it is for the political
leadership of number 10 downing street
i.e the prime minister to then take
steps against those who are responsible
she does say that she's pleased progress
is being made well some progress is
being made but she also says that this
was an issue of leadership of judgement
and of political leadership and that
junior staff and others
uh often only took part in these events
because they were sanctioned by the
prime minister himself because he was at
them and you know that's why he's got to
take responsibility uh for for this
matter and also because he lied to
parliament he came to parliament and he
said no such uh parties took place uh
nothing uh happened and all the rules
were followed and that clearly
is now not the case i mean that's why he
really does need to resign and take
responsibility he argues that he said
that in good faith that he didn't
believe that rules were broken and he
also points to the fact that the police
have only fined him for the one single
event and the other of it the other
events uh that he's alleged to have
taken part in the police actually said
that no rules were broken on his part
well he has got a fine that means he did
break the law that's what that means he
broke the law
quite clearly and i think that is a
resignation offence he broke the law in
number 10 downing street where there
were 126 fines issued if that had been a
restaurant a nightclub a school or a
hospital during the pandemic it would
have been shut down by the authorities
for that level of uh rule breaking and
events uh happening and he says he he
thought that it was within the
guidelines i'm really sorry i mean he's
either
misleading us all and lying which i
believe is the case or he's incredibly
stupid um and you know if he's
incredibly stupid then he's not fit to
be prime minister either and you know i
think the bigger issue here is that
all the while the months and months
we've been uh talking about this issue
and i know your viewers along with
everybody else will on one level being
fed up
of hearing about this whole sorry affair
people's bills have been going through
the roof and the cost of living is
soaring and people are facing real
hardship and challenges and the
government hasn't been able to focus on
these big issues facing the country
because they are at disarray and they
you know they're dysfunctional there's a
problem though isn't there i'm just
taking a step back today
there's a problem because kirsten was
also of course being investigated by
police
for an alleged breach of covered rules
and that makes it very very easy for
boris johnson to throw that right back
at him doesn't it i don't think so
because kirstenberg
unlike boris johnson has said he would
take the ultimate responsibility were he
found to have break and broken the law
and he said that if he is given a fine
which he
uh firmly believes he won't be because
this was uh clearly was a a work
occasion and a work uh break uh to have
a takeaway with only work colleagues in
a small environment there away from home
but that if he is found to have broken
the law then he would resign and that
sets him
massively apart from the prime minister
we are in a situation now aren't we
where it appears more likely that
kierstarma could end up resigning over
partygate than boris johnson well i
don't know that it appears more likely
well it doesn't feel like johnson's
about to resign well no that's because
he won't ever do the honorable thing and
he won't do the right thing and he won't
he's not someone who will take
responsibility for his own so it does
look like actually like it's more likely
that kidama could lose his job over this
then doesn't it well i don't think it's
more likely because i don't think kirst
armour has broken the rules but
obviously i think it's very unlikely
that this particular prime minister
will take responsibility for his own
actions breaking the law in number 10
having parties on an industrial scale
when we couldn't all go to people's
funerals we were having christmas on
zoom uh you know we were missing
birthdays missing loved ones missing
those really important times in life and
the prime minister stood up today in
parliament and seemed to suggest that he
thought it was okay because uh this was
a well-deserving colleague who who
deserved a good toast and a a send-off
uh as a leaving party well i'm sure that
many people watching this program feel
like their close loved ones deserved a
good send-off for dying during covid and
they weren't
able to do that and that is absolutely
appalling and i felt the prime minister
today really had quite a tin ear about
this whole situation he seemed
to sort of bluster his way through
not accepting any responsibility it does
feel um you know as you say that it
looks unlikely that boris johnson is
going to lose his job at least
imminently over this given that you know
three and five voters according to hugo
i think he should resign
electorally is that quite a good thing
for labour
well
i don't i don't think it's a good thing
for the country and i don't think it's a
good thing for politics actually
electorally do you think it might be a
good thing for labour well it's not a
good thing for the conservative party so
in that sense you know maybe so but
actually i'm not really interested in
that to be honest i'm interested in uh
as having a government that's able to
govern and lead and deal with the very
real crisis that people are facing today
which this government isn't able to do
we can't wait for a general election to
solve this cost of living crisis we need
the government to take action now when
we need them to take it on a scale and
at a pace that is consummate with the
crisis that we are facing and they're
just not doing that well we may hear a
bit more on that of course because we
are going to get a statement from the
chancellor uh tomorrow lucy powell thank
you very much for being on the programme
this evening